ah
la pandemia obligado que negocios
míticos en la ciudad de nueva york hayan
tenido que cerrar sus puertas
definitivamente es el caso del hotel
roosevelt que llevaba en pie más de 100
años donde se han grabado muchas
películas entre ellas por ejemplo el
irlandés y este año ha tenido que cerrar
sus puertas tras varios meses de
pérdidas la misma suerte ha corrido la
peluquería ubicada en el east village el
astor place here una peluquería con más
de 75 años de historia que ha visto como
en los últimos meses ha caído un 90 por
ciento su negocio y se ve incapaz de
poder seguir pagando el alquiler de su
espacio hay otros negocios que de
momento han conseguido sobrevivir como
es por ejemplo la conocida librería
extraña su propietaria tras ver una
caída de un 70% del negocio lanzó un
llamamiento de ayuda a través de las
redes sociales y al día siguiente
decenas de newyorkinos se acercaron para
comprar un libro y colaborar y
participar y ayudar a este negocio a que
de momento pueda
en sus puertas abiertas
[Música]
el restaurante madrileño zalacaín ha
echado el cierre definitivo atrás quedan
50 años de historia de un local que
abrió a principios de la década de los
70 y que ha sido escenario de las
primeras reuniones de los gobiernos
democráticos de este país así como
proveedora de la casa real pero sobre
todo el primer restaurante español en
conseguir las tres estrellas michelín
sin embargo este no es más que un
ejemplo emblemático de una crisis que
afecta a toda la hostelería tanto ahora
mismo por la reducción de aforos y de
horarios comerciales como por los
cierres temporales que están decretados
en casi la mitad del territorio español
hemos hablado con la patronal del sector
con hostelería de españa que nos ha
comunicado que sus previsiones son que a
finales de este año alrededor de 100.000
establecimientos lo que supone un tercio
de los que estaban abiertos antes de la
pandemia haya echado el cierre
definitivo una situación que afecta
sobre todo a los pequeños comerciantes
por eso urgen al gobierno que en
materialice el plan de choque para el
sector reiteradamente ha anunciado
[Música]
desde marzo hasta septiembre ese fue el
tiempo de cierre de la actividad no
esencial por la pandemia del cob y 19 en
colombia seis meses sin turismo ni vida
social en los que el 37 por ciento de
las empresas del país han tenido que
cerrar afectando especialmente al sector
servicios y comercio de hecho en agosto
el 40% de restaurantes de bogotá la
capital colombiana habían tenido que
cerrar y un informe del gremio de
restaurantes dijo que nueve mil habían
cerrado y 27.000 quebraron pero no sólo
el sector gastronómico se vio afectado
diversity el parque temático emblemático
de bogotá y medellín cerró sus puertas
para siempre ante la incertidumbre del
futuro así como los almacenes la 14 que
no volverán a abrir en la capital la
cultura también se ha visto afectada con
el cierre de teatros y librería entre
estas pérdidas destaca especialmente la
del cine tonalá una casa cultural que
disponía de dos salas de cine
independiente que también era un
restaurante mexicano y era una tienda y
un lugar reservado para fiestas icónicas
en la ciudad son pérdidas muy
importantes en colombia' que esta semana
entró en recesión por primera vez en dos
décadas
[Música]